voter c'est pour chaque citoyen pour
chacun d'entre nous le moyen d'exprimer
notre voix et de participer à la prise
des décisions qui nous concernent
l'abstention est particulièrement sévère
chez les jeunes elle a été
particulièrement marquée aux élections
municipales de mars et de juin 2020 en
raison du contexte sanitaire mais il n'y
a pas de fatalité et au mouvement
démocrate
nous voulons comprendre les causes de
l'abstention et faire des propositions
pour renforcer la participation du plus
grand nombre aux élections des
propositions pour faire évoluer la loi
mais aussi des propositions pour mettre
en oeuvre des bonnes pratiques sur le
terrain dès les prochains scrutins
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
lançons aujourd'hui cette grande
consultation ouverte pour vous permettre
de vous exprimer
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
procuration vote à distance
représentativité des candidats nous
avons besoin de votre avis sur les
moyens de renforcer la participation
électorale
alors merci à toutes et à tous